She's only 17 years old,
but she's already blazing her own path
and spreading cheer and strength along the way.
Caitlin Thrash is a cheerleader by day,
and a firefighter by night!
(audience cheers and claps)
She is a true wildflower.
She's here.
Please welcome, Caitlin Thrash.
(upbeat music)
(audience claps)
Hello, Caitlin.
Hi.
How are you?
I'm good, how are you?
Oh my goodness, I'm so happy that you're here.
Thank you.
So Caitlin, what, like, inspired the firefighter aspect?
Well, my neighbor is one of our chiefs
and then my other neighbor's an ex-chief.
So, I mean, I would see them leaving all the time
for calls when I was younger.
And then, one night, like, two or three years ago,
they were, like,
"We have a Junior Program at our fire department."
I was like, "Oh, like, okay, like, that's cool."
And after the very first class, I was like,
"This is amazing. I need to continue this."
And then, two years later,
now I'm an active member of the fire department.
(laughs)
(audience cheers and claps)
(Caitlin laughs)
As the mother of two daughters, my jaw is on the floor.
Well, it's prom season.
And, have you been prepping at all?
Honestly? No.
Well, can we think with you?
Of course.
Can we do with you?
Absolutely.
Could we do like a whole transformation
during the hour of the show?
Yeah, definitely.
Really?
Yes.
(laughs)
(audience claps)
I do come from movies
and one thing we all love in movies
whether you're making them or watching them is a make-over.
Am I right?
Oh yeah.
Okay, great.
Because you put the wild in wildflower
but we're still flowers and girls.
So, let's do a movie makeover.
Right, sounds good.
Oh, yeah.
I'm so excited.
All right, this will all take place in the next 60 minutes.
And we're gonna check in with you throughout the show.
That's good.
Okay, now you go backstage and start your process
and then I'll check in with you throughout the hour.
All right, thank you so much.
Throughout the show,
we are following a prom makeover on our guest,
Caitlin Thrash, who is an amazing young woman.
She is a cheerleader.
Oh, and also a firefighter.
(audience cheers and claps)
She is a true wildflower, as we say it on this show,
and prom is all about the dress.
Okay, well, we're gonna check in with them.
Now, it's time to see her final look.
Okay, here is Caitlin before
and here is Caitlin ready for the prom now.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers and claps)
(Caitlin giggles)
How do you feel?
Amazing.
(giggles)
Really?
Yeah, it's so pretty.
(giggles)
And I think you look so lovely.
Aw, thank you.
I really do.
You're so pretty inside and out.
I'm, I don't know why, but I just feel so proud of you
because, you know, we all wanna be strong women who
like do something wonderful in the world
and that's what you're doing.
Thank you.
(giggles)
I'm so impressed by you.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Okay, all right.
Well, I love this dress.
Thank you so much to Sherri Hill for this beautiful dress.
And I can't think of a more beautiful person
that it is laying upon.
And they're the one and only leading prom
and evening wear designers from Austin, Texas.
Go Austin.
One of my favorite places on the globe
and I absolutely love them.
And, we couldn't let you have this magical moment
without sharing it with the people closest to you.
So we'd like to welcome some of your closest friends
from your cheerleading squad and fire station.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers and claps)
Aw!
(giggles)
Hi, guys!
How are you?
Oh, my gosh!
(giggles)
You show up for everybody else,
they wanna show up for you.
I appreciate it.
What do you guys think?
(audience cheers and claps)
Oh my goodness.
Do you feel confident?
Yes, that I do.
(Caitlin laughs)
I mean, what is the difference between this type
of confidence and being a firefighter type-of-confidence?
I know it takes a lot of confidence,
a lot of courage to be a firefighter,
but, I feel pretty good right now, so.
(laughs)
Well, that's having the best of both worlds
which you absolutely deserve.
And I'm also just gonna throw in a $500 gift certificate
to make your prom everything you want it to be and more,
to see you have a little extra spending money
for any little odds and ends
that we didn't take care of here.
Thank you, Caitlin.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Oh my goodness.
Will you tell us how your prom went?
Of course.
Okay, can I see some picture?
Yes, definitely.
Okay. Okay, good.
'Cause I can't let this go.
All right, thank you, everybody, so much for watching.
Thank you to our BFFs.
Thank you to Caitlin's friends!
Your squad of ladies and gentlemen
who you live with and support you right back.
Thanks for showing up, guys.
And, have a wonderful day.
Take this with you.
Thank you so much.
(lively music)